people of the internet's retro Records
who are here and today we are taking a
look at the top 10 spells for PVP in
Harry Potter magic awakens so at number
10 we have a pugno which is one of my
favorite cards I mean the fact that it
only costs 2 MP which I do think you
have to take that into account when
we're ranking this list here the value
of the card compared to what it costs
you and what it gives you in return I
mean for only 2 MP you will summon six
canaries and they can do a total of 168
damage that's with my card being at
level eight right here that is going to
change based on the lovely of your card
but if you have something like a monster
book that's gotten thrown at you a pug
no is great because it's most likely
going to take out that card unless
there's just a huge difference in terms
of the levels there of the card but it
is absolutely a great card has good
range it's going to home in on the
Target and there's really not a great
way to block it you're almost always
going to hit with a Pug no this is also
good if you're running a Bellatrix Echo
because it's going to help you get the
Death Eater even faster I've also seen
this used a lot with the broom sticks
you can use the broomstick go to the
other side of the board maybe have that
opponent who's just kind of lurking in
the very back you want to throw this and
then you throw a broomstick right after
it and you're going to be able to take
them out even if they're kind of sitting
back in the corner for a very low MP
cost of two now the disadvantages I
would say is it's not going to be that
great against your bigger tougher
enemies it can be good to add a little
bit of extra hit to them because you
know you're also going to have your
basic attack going as well so if you've
got them close to finishing them off
then a pug note can be great again the
fact that it only costs 2mp it can also
be really good in Hermione decks if
you're trying to cycle through to get to
her bigger spells because you know as
you use those lower cost spells then
it's going to open up the bigger ones
for you Harry decks it's also great in
that type of deck as well just a really
versatile card and again I mean for 2mp
it is really really strong all right
moving on to number nine we have
expulso yes now I was sleeping on this
card for a while I have to admit you see
the damage you think oh wow only two
damage that's not that great but
honestly this card is far more about the
control aspects than the damage aspect
now yes like a pugno it's such a low MP
cost it only costs 2 MP if you have an
opponent if you have an enemy nearby
that is very weak and almost finished
off then you can just throw this it only
costs 2 and P you know it's not that big
of a deal if you use it however this
card can also really be used for
positioning and this is actually how I
use it a lot let's say you have an enemy
just outside the range of Cassandra's
ring for example you can use that
explosive to actually launch them back
into it or maybe you have someone who's
just sitting inside nebulous or sitting
inside protego diabolica and you want to
knock them out of that for a little bit
you can use expulsa to do that it also
will get you out of orb of water has a
little bit wider of a range than
something like inflatus and it costs 1
MP less than inflated so if somebody's
got you stuck in orb of water you you
can always throw out the spell even if
you miss it only costs 2mp but if you
actually hit then it's going to knock
you free of that now this can also be
very useful in Duo duels so if you have
someone who is getting revived expulso
will knock them out of that now I can't
stress enough guys if you are playing
Duo duels I run into this so much as I
see people not prioritizing preventing
that res it is absolutely insane how
these games can turn because when you
get res you get an overshield and you
get quite a bit more Health than you had
but I have to say when it comes to dual
duels I really feel like a lot of the
people that I match up with they just
aren't prioritizing finishing off that
opponent when they're going for that res
you have one down if you have the other
one at all close to finishing them off
prioritize knocking them out of that res
using something like inflatus or like
exploso incredibly versatile spell and
again it only costs 2mp so just a really
good value there okay at number eight we
have whiz bang now this card is
currently banned right now in the PVP
mode for the game people were really
really using this card a lot and
honestly this one would be even higher
but there are two things working against
it first of all it does cost 7 MP so one
of the highest costs in the game and you
pretty much don't want to use this card
without pairing it with something else
like inflatus is the one that I see a
lot of people using and then also uh
incarceros is the other one that people
use this in conjunction with it does
work very very well in a Hermione deck
because you can use those lower cost
spells to reduce the cost of this and
when you get this thing down to costing
a lot cheaper than seven I mean the bang
that you're getting here no pun intended
by the way the bang for your buck is
just incredible with this card if you
get someone trapped with incarceress and
then you hit them with this it is just
massive massive damage that can totally
change a game and honestly right now now
there aren't very many counters to this
card I think that's probably why people
were fed up and had it banned for this
week I mean you can use the broomstick a
little bit you can use uh manticores
baby manticores to kind of help out to
try and get away from this card but at
the end of the day it paired with
incarceros I also think incarceros has
something going on right now where it
kind of extends out a little bit more
than it probably should I feel like
sometimes I'm even out of the range of
incarceros and it'll still kind of pull
me in anyway but the way that people are
using this card right now is just
incredibly incredibly strong now we said
this is a PVP list this card is also
really good in PVE as well in the right
situations I mean you look right here in
the video when you can get multiple
enemies like that it's just insane you
don't see it used as much in solos I
mean I do see some people use it and use
it very well but I see it far more often
in dual duels and if both people are
running this card
it's just incredible now the one
disadvantage again is that it costs so
much MP so if you're not running a
Hermione deck it's kind of tough to use
this card but if you are running a
Hermione deck then it is just absolutely
incredible I mean look at the damage
right here I think at some point they're
probably gonna have to Nerf this card
and maybe also Nerf the range of
incarceros as well I mean I guess when
you balance it with the fact that it
does cost you so much to use it your
goal if you're facing this card my
approach to it has been just trying to
overwhelm the opponent throw so many
things at them that they have to use
their resources they have to use their
MP to take care of the enemies around
them because if you just let them sit
back and they get to build up the meter
on this card and they get to have enough
MP to use this and incarceros then it's
really incredibly tough to deal with now
we mentioned the monster book once
already and it comes in at number seven
on our list with only a cost of three MP
three damage image so it's a little bit
more than something like expulso but the
biggest advantage of the monster book is
how it races across the board you can
use this to take out a niffler you can
use this to take out someone's bomb box
and you can also pair it with your bomb
box to do even more damage it's just an
incredibly versatile card and the fact
that it only costs 3MP it's crazy man
it's so annoying I mean it'll just it'll
go and Destroy someone's bomb box it'll
destroy someone's niffler now another
great way to use this card is it will
also eat away at the Norwegian Ridgeback
egg which is a really powerful card if
someone puts that egg down you know they
have an amount of time where they have
to get that egg to hatch so you need to
be doing as much damage as you possibly
can this the monster book pair with
something like atmospheric charm or the
monster book and something like incendio
they can really do a lot of work at
taking down that Norwegian Ridgeback
before it ever even really gets going
and number six on our list we have
incendio there's is a card I have
focused on upgrading I've gotten it up
to level 10. it does cost 4 MP but this
card I actually like it a little bit
more than confringo confringo costs one
more MP and can be stronger in a lot of
situations but incendio for me is much
more reliable you have that little ring
that clearly defined area where you know
it's going to go now one crazy thing
about this card if someone uses we just
talk about the monster book which is a
good card stack of Monster books I
really like that card I really do
however if someone is running incendio
and it is at that level or higher than
their monster book card then it is just
going to absolutely shred all three of
those Monster books you just have to
make sure you let them get in close and
that they all stay inside that ring when
you use it now one thing that I myself
have had to work on and have seen a lot
of people do is they'll throw incendio
when they're walking back from enemies
now with a lot of enemies you don't want
to do this because they will keep
approaching they are following you they
are tracking you and so if you throw
that incendio they're not going to get
caught in the full area of that spell
now incendio can also be very helpful if
someone is just sitting and hiding a
nebulous maybe you throw a thunderstorm
and then you have enough MP left using
sendio kind of wait a little bit see if
they go into nebulous and then you can
throw that incendio there because they
definitely do not want to just sit there
and take incendio because it does do
pretty solid damage as well I mean you
have a four damage here you could also
pair this with something like inflatus
something like incarcers where if you
hit them with that and then throw down
an incendio as well doesn't do quite as
much damage as something like whiz-bang
but again it only costs 4mp now another
reason that you want to make sure you
stay close to those enemies when you're
using incendio that you don't walk away
is because of this right here the closer
enemies are to the center of the flame
the more damage they take so you want to
make sure that they are positioned at
the dead center of the flame and if
you're moving around then they're going
to start moving around they're not going
to take that full damage right there
this can be very helpful against
Superior totem locomotives which are
really strong right now it's going can
also be very helpful against antipody
and opolis even though they're flying
the incendio will still hit them again
you want to make sure that you're
staying relatively close though because
if you're moving around too much then
they're just going to be moving in and
out of that incendio ring really any
time that you get overwhelmed by a group
of enemies like you know if someone's
throwing a bunch of Cornish Pixies if
they're throwing spiders at you if
they're throwing Monster books at you
all of those enemies you can kind of let
collect in close and then use incendio
and it's just an incredibly powerful
card okay at number five we have a card
that I don't personally use a lot maybe
because I just got it but I have to say
I have faced a lot of players running
orb of water and it is incredibly
difficult to deal with which is why it
comes in at number five on our list
today it does cost 6 MP to use but it
does a lot of damage and not only that
you can also use it as a control spell
as well as you're going to be able to
move these enemies around you can
actually catch multiple enemies in this
and I can't tell you how many times I
have seen people get caught in the orb
of water and then make another mistake
like maybe they throw Ron out there as a
companion then Ron gets caught in the
orb of water as well but you compare
this with so many other things in Duo
duels as well oh my goodness I mean I've
seen people run Hermione as a companion
so they'll throw Hermione and then
they'll have double orb of water or
maybe you've got the uh Duo player
throwing incendio down throwing uh whiz
bang down while they're caught in the
orb of water it's just an incredibly
powerful card with really not a lot of
counters I mean you can use exploso you
can use inflatus to get out of it but
even then as long as you're moving
around which this is the big key using
this card whenever you have someone
caught in it you want to make sure that
you're moving around make your movements
unpredictable you don't want to be easy
to hit with something like exploso or
inflators because then you're going to
get knocked out of it and you're not
going to get the full damage now one
thing here is you really want to try and
make sure that you hold them to the end
at the end of casting the orb will
explode dealing massive damage so that
is the part that you want to make sure
that you hold them all the way to the
end because if they get out before the
end or if they get out at that part
let's say they use like broomstick or
something so they're caught in the first
wave of it but then they kind of get out
right to the end you're not going to get
the full damage especially the big burst
at the end right there at number four we
have pure totem locomotor absolutely one
of the strongest spells in the game
right now especially if the person is
running the Hagrid Echo they are
incredibly tanky tanky boys when they
drop in their damage is reduced by 99 so
don't even waste an attack when they
first drop in do not waste an attack on
them because it's basically going to do
absolutely nothing they also have
377 Health front row a four star ranking
right there damage 55 but of course
that's just with one hit because they
are going to attack and attack and
attack until you take them out so
incendio can be really strong against
them confringo can be really strong
against them in the right situations Ron
can also be really strong against them
but if you have someone that's running
Hagrid and they're running like swelling
solution and they're running these guys
I mean you absolutely have to prioritize
getting rid of them as fast as possible
just make sure you don't do it when
they're taunting again because it's not
going to do anything now if you're
looking for counters another really
strong way to go against these guys is
using something like Ventus because
that's going to buy you a little bit of
extra time you push them away with that
wind they're going to be taking damage
while you do it it gives your MP time to
build so you can plan what you're going
to do next and also just keeps them off
of you because once they get in close
you really don't have a lot of options
to that point you could throw something
like inflators you can throw something
like incendio to try and take them out
as well and number three just edging out
the pure totem locomotor we have the
antipodian opal eye which once again
paired with the Hagrid deck is
incredibly incredibly strong paired with
swelling solution oh my goodness when
you increase the attack rate how fast
this thing is breathing fire it is
incredible what this thing can do four
damage ranking right there
362 Health DPS of 19.6 damage of 59 but
it's the range and the fact that they
are in the air that makes them even more
difficult to deal with I think than pure
totem locomotor now if you watch up here
in the video they can also be incredibly
helpful at dealing with Spam I mean
because of that AOE damage just look at
that one burst of fire I know spiders
aren't very strong but one burst of fire
and they just absolutely obliterate them
and then also get to work on the trolls
as well and to putting an opal eye
really it's hard for me to find any
negative about this card right now I
mean it does cost 6 MP there's not
really any way to reduce that either
since it's not a spell not even Hermione
is going to be able to reduce the cost
of that so you are going to have to pay
the price with the six total MP cost
there but just a very strong card right
now and also incredibly strong in the
forest again I know it's a PVP deck but
if you're running this in the forest and
Hagrid it's just it's dominant all right
so what could possibly top pure totem
locomotor and the antipodian opal eye
well I have thunderstorm right here
coming in at number two on our list now
the only reason that I rate thunderstorm
a little bit higher than these is
because of the fact that it is that much
more difficult to counter yes I know
about nebulous however there are so many
ways to get the player out of nebulous
when you have someone running this and
they're running like a Bellatrix deck or
something maybe they're running Hermione
companion as well they throw Hermione
then they throw the double thunderstorm
especially if you are the only player
and you don't have any summons on
Battlefield with you right then you're
going to take so much damage from this
and it's essentially guaranteed hits
there's nothing you do about it unless
you go into nebulous that's really it
you could also get a lot of other
enemies on the battlefield so they'll
try and spread out some of the damage as
well that can actually work to your
disadvantage sometimes because for each
opponent that the lightning defeats its
name image increases by 10 percent and
it can stack up to five times so let's
say you have a bunch of spiders out on
the battlefield if the lightning takes
them out then it's just going to
increase the damage that it's doing to
you I mean so this is great for ad
control this is great for if you have
just one opponent on the field at a time
now it's not only good in a Bellatrix
deck you can also use this in a Hermione
deck and when you get that MP cost down
because it is a spell it's not a summon
it's just ridiculous man it's ridiculous
that you can have a card like this then
if you throw something like oh I don't
know pre-orient cantato in there as well
the fact that you could have this card
back to back and then if you have a
Hermione as well as your companion
it could just put out a ridiculous
amount of damage and because the fact
that it is almost unblockable that's why
it's number two on my list all right
what could possibly top all of those
cards at number one on our list you guys
probably already know because the fact
that we haven't talked about it yet and
of course in any kind of PVP list we
have to talk about the bomb box that's
number one on our list the bombtastic
bomb box now I know what you're thinking
retro how can this car possibly be
number one because on its own it's
really not that strong and that is true
however it only cost 3 MP which means
that you are going to be able to pair
this with something like Cornish Pixies
with something like the cats with
something like the monster book and do
massive massive damage this card is
essentially what helped me get all the
way from a novice to a grand master now
I would check my stats at the end of a
lot of these games and almost every
single time the card with the most
damage more than thunderstorm more than
hope alive I was running it more than
pure totem locomotor more than incendio
it was always the bombtastic bomb box
because of just how much damage it puts
out when it's tossing those Bombs all
out across the field to all your other
little allies and I kid you not that is
how I got to Grand Master now if you
guys want to hear more PVP tips for how
I went from novice to Grand Master I
already have a video on that here on the
channel I'll link it over there on the
right side of your screen now as always
guys thank you all so much for watching
I'll talk to you again soon